Est-ce que quelqu'un sait ce qui lui est arrivé,
quelqu'un me dit si elle est toujours en vie
[Musique]
où était-elle
où était Nicola pendant trois semaines ? Je
ne crois pas qu'elle soit morte, est-ce qu'elle est dans cette
rivière, c'est ce que je veux dire, elle n'est jamais
entrée dans cette eau
non  nous ne faisons pas Tick Tock Je ne suis pas un
détective Je ne suis pas Sherlock Holmes,
allez-y,
ils ont été une nuisance ou un obstacle
dans l'aquarium en 29 ans Service de police
Je n'ai jamais rien vu de pareil et
nous y sommes maintenant  le cinquième jour de recherche
de Brian Laundry, vous ne trouvez pas cela
suspect
vous ne trouvez pas cela vidéos suspectes
[Musique]
Sonoma
est
[Musique]
quand j'ai regardé dans ma boule de cristal, c'est
bien un outil de divination, alors qu'est-ce que nous avons
les gars et  les filles, je crois que c'est
quelque part par ici où Nicola a
disparu, nous avons localisé environ trois zones
qui correspondent à cette description si nous pouvions
simplement y entrer pour les fouiller, ce serait
absolument encore mieux qu'elle soit dans cette
rivière, qu'elles soient
ou non  nous la trouverons, nous
examinerons ensuite mais est-ce qu'elle est dans la rivière
n'est pas dans la
rivière elle n'est pas dans la rivière elle n'est pas tombée
dans la rivière
elle n'est pas tombée dans la rivière,
euh il s'est passé quelque chose
quelque chose qu'elle n'a pas nécessairement
vu  à venir
mais on dirait qu'elle pourrait encore gagner
sa liberté, pensez à la discussion,
c'est
[Musique]
en espérant qu'elle soit toujours en vie,
mais peu importe, mon opinion est la famille,
il est tous responsable, pas tellement toute
la famille, mais il y avait certainement
des signaux d'alarme.  Je ne dis pas que son
mari a quelque chose à voir avec ça, mais les
problèmes conjugaux sont quelque chose qu'ils doivent
examiner, ils doivent le faire. Je
ne pense sérieusement pas qu'elle soit tombée dans cette rivière. Je,
sérieusement, je ne pense pas que je serai choqué si
c'est la raison.  les résultats sont choqués, nous
devons donc projeter le scénario numéro
deux, c'est qu'elle n'est pas tombée dans la rivière,
elle a été
enlevée dans cette zone, je
pense que
deux pêcheurs ont été repérés louches
la veille, si vous vouliez
enlever quelqu'un de cette région du lac, vous le
feriez  va chercher un permis de pêche
c'est juste pour les filles c'est tout je suis là
pour elles c'est tout pour moi et les
filles ce n'est plus pour elle il
remercie les gens pour leur soutien ce
niveau de soutien et non leur
aide il introduit de la complexité
et  données et difficulté à la retrouver
au lieu d'encourager les gens à m'aider.
J'identifie correctement qu'il
mentait
lorsqu'elle a disparu mais que quelqu'un d'autre
l'a fait. Ce n'est pas le comportement que je
m'attendrais à voir de la part de quiconque est
trompeur ou essaie de cacher quelque chose.
là, je veux dire, il est même ouvert si ce type
cache quelque chose de puissant, un
très bon langage corporel et l'un de nous
aurait du mal à le faire, mon
avis
est
donc mesdames et messieurs, c'est l'endroit
ici, euh, au centre de l'image, vous verrez
un  banc en bois marron sous l'arbre
oui, c'est l'endroit exact
où elle a été vue pour la dernière fois. Il est intéressant
de noter que la police
n'a pas
sécurisé cette zone de manière médico-légale. Je ne suis pas un
détective, je ne suis pas Sherlock Holmes,
juste l'homme avec une caméra, mais je crois.
il n'y a aucun mal à descendre ici et à
jeter un oeil car vous pouvez voir que
c'est très boueux et glissant maintenant
si vous tombez ici,
vous ne pourrez pas grimper
sur cette rive, que pensez-vous qu'il s'est passé,
je dirais  c'est
vraiment pourquoi ne pensez-vous pas qu'elle est sur la
rivière, vous avez fouillé la rivière
de manière approfondie d'ici à la mer,
donc c'est le plan d'eau
où elle aurait été ce premier
jour ou deux trois jours par semaine,
je veux dire quoi  tu penses que tout le monde
pense qu'elle aurait été là-dedans
et n'aurait pas pu être trouvée
je veux dire personnellement je je ne peux pas le voir tu
sais
je ne peux pas le voir personnellement
je pourrais aussi bien s'il te laisse
passer bravo mon pote merci
Fury,
elle a été arrachée ensuite sur la petite
rivière suivante dans un bateau non ici ouais,
puis pas devant la caméra, puis déchargée
quelque part ici et Andrew dans une camionnette
ouais,
c'est toujours toujours verrouillé 24 heures sur 24, 7 jours sur 7. Les
créateurs de vidéos sur les réseaux sociaux et veulent être
détectés pour qu'ils  J'ai été une nuisance ou
un obstacle pour l'environnement au cours de mes 29
années de service de police. Je n'ai jamais
rien vu de pareil. Nous demandons aux
gens de la communauté au sens large,
en particulier sur les réseaux sociaux et en ligne, de
ne pas spéculer sur ce qui a pu
arriver à Nicola.
non, nous ne faisons pas de tic tac
non, en fait,
techniquement, nous faisons du journalisme, que
pensez-vous que vous faites bien parce que c'était
ouvert, nous sommes entrés, le monsieur ici a
dit qu'il appartenait à une charmante dame, si elle est là,
elle en parlera  toi là tu pars tu
vas sur vous deux donc vous n'avez pas pas
de mots à dire non non non rien non je
suppose qu'il avait
eu euh il vient de dire qu'il vend sa
caravane
merci
Google d'abord mon premier mon premier point  est-
ce vrai,
juste
je comprends ce que tu fais ouais j'ai
vu ta chaîne YouTube tu as ouais
je suis absolument une chaîne YouTube et j'ai
le but de ouais
ouais ok devrais-je te dire ce qui
s'est passé aujourd'hui, écoute-moi juste une
minute, n'est-ce pas  quand il s'agit des
résidents locaux, oui, vous pourriez être plus
respectueux de ce que vous faites, vous
alimentez un incendie en ligne qui accuse.
J'essaie en fait de
redresser la situation, mais il y a d'autres personnes qui
ne le sont pas et et  en continuant,
juste
si quelque chose, j'essaie d'arrêter les
spéculations qui sont différentes,
écoutez-moi simplement, nous en arrivons au point
où si c'est une réaction comme celle-là et qu'il
y a d'autres personnes qui vont réagir
comme ça, cela finira par arriver  un
point où je devrais vous arrêter
avant de violer le prêtre pour éviter que vous ne
soyez blessé, soyez simplement plus conscient
du fait que la population locale en a assez
des YouTubers et des tick-tockers, il
a été rapporté que Sowella Braverman,
le ministre de l'Intérieur, a exigé que  La
police du Lancashire explique pourquoi elle a
révélé des informations personnelles sur l'
intimidateur de Nicola. La police du Lancashire a été
critiquée pour avoir rendu public ses
problèmes d'alcool et les
médias sur la ménopause ont adopté un
angle selon lequel les YouTubeurs, les tiques
et les médias sociaux salissent l'affaire
ou manquent de respect.  ou interférer
avec l'enquête et peut-être que c'est
aussi bien quand la police fait
des erreurs. Sully, sa bonne réputation, c'est peut-être
aussi bien que des gens à travers le
pays
viennent enquêter par eux-mêmes
comme je l'ai fait.
Merci,
malheureusement, nous sommes maintenant en mesure de le faire.  pour confirmer
qu'hier nous avons récupéré Nicola Bully
du massage au fil de la rivière,
nos filles recevront le soutien dont elles ont besoin
de la part des personnes qui les aiment le plus
et cela nous attriste de penser qu'un jour
nous devrons leur expliquer que la
presse
et les membres  du public
accuse leur père d'actes
répréhensibles, les amis et la famille sont mal cités et vilipendés,
c'est absolument épouvantable,
ils doivent être tenus pour responsables, cela
ne peut pas arriver à une autre famille,
c'est l'
un des aspects les plus troublants de
l'affaire Nicola Broly, en particulier,
ce sentiment presque palpable de
déception que certaines personnes ont ressentie
lorsqu'il s'est avéré qu'il ne s'agissait pas d'un meurtre,
mais je n'accepterai jamais que cette
dame soit tombée dans cette rivière et ait dérivé
là où elle était pour finir là où elle n'a pas été
retrouvée trois semaines plus tard et bien sûr,
beaucoup  les gens insistent toujours sur le fait qu'il
y a eu un jeu déloyal, pourquoi parce que
cela fait une meilleure histoire
de faire une vidéo sur la rivière de cette façon,
si vous savez qui je suis, vous savez à quoi sert
YouTube, vous
savez pourquoi les gens posent évidemment
des questions.  plus les gens
comprennent, moins il y a de spéculations si vous
croyez la police ce qu'elle dit, c'est
vrai, c'est votre choix personnellement,
beaucoup de gens ne le font pas et ils veulent voir
justice pour une personne innocente, c'est vrai.
Fascinations
Je pense aussi qu'il y a une tendance
à  faire
des jeunes et des plateformes comme Tick
Tock le bouc émissaire des tendances et
des médias qui existent depuis très
très longtemps. Je veux dire, ce n'est pas comme si la
conduite d'organisations comme la BBC
et Sky News était irréprochable dans l'
affaire d'intimidation de Nicola et évidemment  il y a
une très très longue histoire de
couverture médiatique abusive et sensationnaliste de
crimes très médiatisés qui existaient avant
même l'arrivée d'Internet. L'
affaire d'intimidation de Nicola nous a donné l'occasion
collectivement de nous regarder dans le
miroir et de dire ce que nous faisons quand nous
euh  exploiter la douleur des gens de cette manière et
peut-être une question encore meilleure : pourquoi y a-t-il
un si grand public pour la
consommation du traumatisme des autres.
La portion
[Musique]